[Musique]
gravé sur une façade du château de
versailles à toutes les gloires de la
france l'inscription à peut-être motivé
le général en retraite philippe morillon
tout près boulevard du roi le député
européen repart au front électoral armes
aux pieds je rentre en campagne
en clair donc chez d'une compétition
l'udf la parachuter à la dernière minute
candidat aux législatives dans la
circonscription de versailles chevreuse
un bastion de droite libéré par le
député sortant franck borotra
l'ancien élève du trait versailles et
lycée hoche se dit chez lui même s'il
avoue méconnaître les problèmes locaux
ces affiches encore sous presse le
retardataire justifie son combat j'ai
respect de
l'électeur
pouvoir continuer de lui laisser son
choix en a pas lui imposer une
candidature unique là où il n'y a pas de
menace qu'à la faveur d'une concurrence
on fasse passer ceux qui partagent pas
nos idéaux face à lui quatre adversaires
de droite dont valérie pécresse la
candidate investie par l'union pour la
majorité présidentielle de 30 ans sa
cadette ex conseillère à l'elysée sept
autres parachutes et soutenue par les
barons locaux avec eux la parisienne
arpente la circonscription
j'ai fait demi km en voiture j'ai fait
cinq réunions publiques déjà j'en ai
sept en préparation les gens me
demandent tous les jours de venir leur
parler dans leur petit village
c'est une impression extraordinaire
dans vide politique et moi je m'amuse
la conseillère d'état n'a pas la
notoriété du général alors sourire
charmeur elle se présente au début de
chaque réunion publique
j'ai juge tous les laisse produire entre
l'état et la titration autre femme en
liste la candidate de gauche prg ps à
militante associative avocate au
barreau de versailles cet élu municipal
revendique son implantation locale
j'ai quelque chose de tout à fait unique
je suis un ovni je suis la seule fille
lui de terrain qui se présente aux
élections par rapport à mettre deux
candidats
potentiels de la droite qui sont avec
leurs parachutes en or massif dans cette
circonscription très à droite la
candidate chiraquienne devait être élu
dans un fauteuil le débarquement du
général morillon pour l'udf relance la
compétition
[Musique]